qué tal cómo están
bueno yo soy el ortiz hoy psicoterapeuta
coach de vida y autora y es un placer
enorme estar aquí esta noche y quiero
comenzar a abrir este espacio con una
pregunta una pregunta que recibí hace un
tiempo a través de un correo electrónico
y la verdad es que cuando yo la leí lo
primero que pensé fue jamás nunca nadie
me había hecho esa pregunta y quiero que
la escuchen en esta tarde pero quiero
que lo hagan de una forma diferente así
que les voy a pedir que por favor
cierres tus ojos cierra tus ojos unos
segundos
y en ese silencio
hasta la siguiente pregunta
cómo está tu corazón
cuáles han sido sus emociones estos
últimos días miedo
angustia
o tranquilidad como están hoy tus
relaciones con esas personas importantes
en tu vida con tus hijos cómo está tu
trabajo te sientes satisfecho con los
resultados en tu trabajo
cómo está tu cuerpo cada día más cansado
adolorido
cómo estás abre tus ojos
quiero compartirles una frase que me
parece muy poderosa el hombre que no
tiene vida interior es esclavo de su
entorno
el hombre que no tiene una vida interior
es esclavo de su entorno qué significa
vivir en piloto automático vivir en
piloto automático significa justo siendo
esclavo de tu entorno
aguantando aguantando aguantando solo
reaccionando y no respondiendo suceden
cosas y no sabes qué hacer así que vivir
en piloto automático es vivir víctima de
tu historia víctima de las
circunstancias víctimas de tus
pensamientos de tus emociones
hace aproximadamente 11 años y con un
corazón roto comenzó lo que me gusta
llamar mi despertar de conciencia
apagar el piloto automático es ponerlo
en manual un poco y detenerte a mirar el
paisaje y si miras hoy el paisaje de tu
vida ese paisaje es de terror es de
drama o es de tranquilidad cómo está el
paisaje en tu vida hoy yo creo que toda
persona genera cambios en su vida desde
dos espacios o lo hacemos desde la
inspiración desde una decisión
consciente o lo hacemos desde la
desesperación y ahí estaba yo en una
relación más que había fracasado después
de muchas otras que también donde
terminé siendo una persona que no me
gustaba donde terminé cediendo a cosas
solo con tal de que esa persona no se
fuera de mi lado me aterraba estar sola
así que apague el piloto automático dije
basta de una voz dentro de mí que me
decía por favor it's el as algo hay otra
forma de vivir la forma en que lo has
venido haciendo la forma en que has
venido pensando actuando ya no está
funcionando te lleva siempre a los
mismos callejones sin salida te llevas
siempre esas situaciones dolorosos
de conflicto así que apague el piloto
automático y comencé una de las tareas
más complicadas que tenemos como seres
humanos la ardua tarea de conocerme a mí
misma
así que después de mi propio proceso de
conciencia de crecimiento de evolución
de desarrollo como lo quieras llamar y
además acompañando ya desde hace unos
años a las personas a través de su
propio proceso en la psicoterapia en el
consultorio me doy cuenta que hay una
serie de claves etapas que
necesariamente por las cuales tienes que
pasar para generar cambios permanentes
reales sostenidos en el tiempo en tu
vida si así lo ha decidido probablemente
probablemente muchos aquí estamos justo
en ese proceso
entonces el número cero piloto
automático apenas sobreviviendo y
entonces llega el caos llega la crisis
llega el tocar fondo y dices basta y si
eres valiente vas a comenzar el viaje o
si no simplemente te quedas en la
negación a mí no me afecta yo estoy bien
pero llega esa enfermedad llega ese
ataque de pánico llega ese diagnóstico
de enfermedad llega ese fuerte dolor en
el pecho llega ese conflicto fuerte con
tu pareja con tu familia y entonces si
lo decides apagas el piloto automático y
comenzamos el viaje comienza el viaje el
viaje del autoconocimiento en donde
tienes que responder a las preguntas
porque actuó como actuó porque pienso
como pienso porque me afecta tanto la
opinión de otros porque soy tan exigente
conmigo al grado incluso de dejar pasar
oportunidades porque me aterré
equivocarme porque me cuesta expresar
mis emociones porque me cuesta tanto
decirle a mis hijos a mi pareja te amo
porque me cuesta tanto entonces en ese
camino de autoconocimiento
necesariamente tiene que ocurrir algunas
cosas primero tienes que echarte un
clavado profundo una reflexión profunda
en tu historia es necesario porque tu
historia te marcó su historia definió tu
forma de verte a ti de ver el mundo así
que necesariamente tienes que ir a tocar
historia y probablemente vas a tocar
esas experiencias de tu pasado que
dolieron y por eso muchos de nosotros no
queremos entrar en esa ardua tarea de
conocernos a nosotros mismos porque nos
da miedo aterra y aparte tengo miedo por
kitsch él me va a doler hay personas que
llegan a mi consultorio y me dicen is el
yo sé que tengo que terminar esa
relación pero me va a doler
y entonces yo le pregunto a esa persona
no te está doliendo ya
así que entramos en esa reflexión de
nuestra historia y uno de los favores
más grandes que te puedes hacer a ti
mismo es aprender cómo funciona tu mente
porque si tú aprendes a cómo funciona tu
mente entonces vas a lograr salir más
rápido de esos estados de sufrimiento si
tú sabes cómo funciona tu mente vas a
saber que hay una gran diferencia entre
el dolor y el sufrimiento así que
empieza el camino del autoconocimiento
necesitas responder a esas preguntas
porque actuó como actuó porque siempre
repito los mismos comportamientos una y
otra vez porque vivir en piloto
automático precisamente es vivir
inconscientes sin darnos cuenta así que
vamos avanzando y vamos a la siguiente
etapa tomo mayor control muy bien ya me
doy cuenta porque me irrito tanto porque
explotó porque me cuesta tanto confiar
en mí porque me cuesta tanto expresar
mis emociones ya me doy cuenta ya me doy
cuenta y hoy además entiendo que soy
100% responsable de mis experiencias 150
no 80
por ciento responsable de mis
experiencias probablemente cuando éramos
niños adolescentes
dependiendo emocionalmente
económicamente físicamente de otras
personas no podíamos hacer mucho pero
hoy hoy ya eres 100% responsable de tus
experiencias y en ese punto con un mayor
sentido de responsabilidad yo observo
como las personas que llegan a mi
consultorio me empiezan a decir y se le
empieza a ser un poco más paciente
empieza a ser un poco más tolerante
empiezo a atreverme un poco más empiezo
a aprender a decir no cuando es
necesario entonces tomó mayor control de
mi vida ya me doy cuenta soy 100%
responsable y ocurre en esos pequeños
pero grandes milagros y te experimentas
siendo y haciendo de forma diferente
entonces ya no se vale decir es que así
soy yo
ya no se vale decir es que así soy yo
has tomado mayor responsabilidad de tu
vida y crece tu nivel de conciencia me
doy cuenta y entonces vamos pasando a la
siguiente etapa tus recursos porque no
sirve de nada que yo sepa porque me
cuesta tanto expresar lo que siento si
no tengo los recursos las estrategias la
forma para poder salir de ese patrón
común de comportamiento entonces no
sirve de nada que yo me eché un clavado
en mi historia entienda por qué actuó
como actuó por qué pienso como pienso si
no voy a estar dispuesto a hacer lo que
se requiere para comenzar a generar esos
cambios y empezar a experimentar me
siendo una persona diferente pensando de
manera distinta haciéndolo de forma
diferente entonces cuáles son tus
recursos cuáles son tus recursos físicos
mentales emocionales o espirituales el
que tú quieras el que te funciona mejor
recursos como por ejemplo meditación
recursos como por ejemplo
anclas mentales poderosas frases muy
concretas y esto lo utilizo muchísimo
con mis pacientes en terapia frases
concretas para cuando llega ese
pensamiento pesimista para cuando llega
ese pensamiento que te llena de miedo
utiliza esas anclas mentales poderosas
para salir de esos espacios de
sufrimiento cuáles son tus recursos a lo
mejor el ejercicio a lo mejor salir a
caminar en la naturaleza cuáles son tus
recursos en este punto yo me doy cuenta
que las personas renuncian con mayor
facilidad a aquello que les hace daño
hay mayor confianza hay mayor amor y por
lo tanto ya no me engancho tan
fácilmente y si lo hago tengo mis
recursos para salir de ese espacio de
sufrimiento cuáles son tus recursos
cuáles son esos recursos que te llevan a
regresar a ti a regresar a tu calma a
regresar a tu centro para que desde ahí
desde un estado de mayor calma entonces
yo pueda decidir quién quiero ser frente
a la situación que está ocurriendo
cuáles son tus recursos
y entonces pasamos a la siguiente parte
que me encanta y a muchos cuando les
mencioné este título se les hace
bastante gracioso pero es afinación y
balanceo
afinación y balanceo alineación y
balanceo qué significa eso bueno estamos
en un viaje y ese coche necesita esa
revisión y además también en este punto
que pasa muchas personas llegan a la
terapia y me dicen it's el gym otra vez
me enganché chin
otra vez explotó otra vez renuncie otra
vez qué creés le hablé al exnovio y
entonces llega ese momento en el que
creen que han retrocedido pero lo
primero que le digo a esa persona es por
favor no creas que ha retrocedido por
favor no creas que no ha servido de nada
todo el esfuerzo que has hecho por favor
no lo creas porque es muy común que las
personas sientan que han retrocedido
pero la realidad es que para mí estos
sucesos que vienen a probar de estos
sucesos
es como aquello que ya había superado
dices chin yo creía haberlo superado y
otra vez que hay en la misma situación
para mí es la forma en que la vida te
dice hay tema de nuevo y vamos a ver si
esta vez si lo vas a hacer diferente
vamos a ver si esta vez ya no vas a
tropezar con la misma piedra entonces
estas situaciones se presentan estos
retos esto que te viene a mover a
incomodar se presenta para que salga a
flote aquello que necesitas seguir
trabajando aquello lo que necesita
seguir creciendo aquello que necesitas
seguir cultivando porque cuando estamos
en estos procesos de conciencia porque
cuando estamos en estos procesos de
crecimiento no significa que ya no me
voy a enojar
porque está la típica esposa al esposo
de la mamá de pues es una que está
llegando a terapia como que no te está
ayudando mucho sigues enojando te sigues
desesperando te como que no te está
sirviendo mucho eso de llegar a terapia
pero la realidad es que no significa
como les decía hace un momento que ya no
me voy a enojar que ya no me voy a
desesperar significa que ya me voy a
salir mucho más rápido y voy a pasar
menos tiempo de lo necesario en esos
espacios de sufrimiento
así que vamos avanzando en ese proceso y
te vas experimentando como te decía de
forma diferente tomas mayor
responsabilidad si no te gustan los
resultados que están obteniendo en tus
finanzas en tu relación de pareja
entonces tú sabes que eres el único
responsable y quién puede hacer algo
para que eso sea diferente porque nadie
más va a ser por tu vida lo que tú no
estés dispuesto a hacer alineación y
balanceo así que queridos yo hoy
simplemente te quiero invitar a que
hagas esa revisión de si estás llevando
tu vida en piloto automático si sigues
viviendo esa vida inconsciente solo
aguantando aguantando como un ente
pasivo recibiendo golpe tras golpe
creyendo que no puedes hacer nada
entonces apaga el piloto automático y
comienza a crear la vida que merece tu
alma apaga el piloto automático y
comienza a crear intencionalmente esa
vida llena de mayor satisfacción de
mayor sentido de mayor alegría de mayor
felicidad una vida de disfrute que
significa disfrutar significa dar
y conecta con mayor alegría y conecta
con mayor con mayor amor porque de rivas
esas barreras que creaste para ya no
sufrir más pero esas barreras no están
dejando que pasa el dolor pero tampoco
están dejando que pase el amor así que
deseo que apagues el piloto automático y
comiences tu propio despertar de
conciencia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]